>> This is a test. We are
testing the system.
This is a test.
>> This is a test. This is a
test.  This is a test.
>> This is a test. test. We
are testing the system.  This is
a test.  We are testing the
system.
>> Good morning! morning! Good
morning!
(Applause.)
Good morning!
And welcome to a very, very
special day at the Library of
Congress, I'm Carla Hayden and I
can't tell you how excited we
are because today we are
celebrating literacy and
learning and
reading and we couldn't ask for
a better person and organization
to collaborate with today.
Today our special guest is an
advocate
for books and the power of the
written word for children.
We are honored to have here at
the
Library of Congress multi award
win be
p
hilanthropist.  Dolly Parton.  I
think it's time to clap!
I want to and I would be remiss
if I didn't introduce some
special guests in
the audience, the wonderful
staff and the leadership of the
Dollywood foundation, led by Mr.
David Dodson, they have been
wonderful to work with!  There
is Mr. Dodson.
We are delighted to have members
of
Congress, members of the
Washington city council, our
various partners in literacy and
collaborators and our generous
donors who make so much
possible because today we're all
here as cheerleaders for books
and learning.
Now, I have to tell you, when I
started as a children's
librarian I
remember being inspired by a
young woman
who was on the south side of
Chicago and
her name was Judy Zucher and
when I first walked into that
branch library she was on the
floor having story time with
children with ought simple.
simple.
She was telling stories and it's
wonderful where imagination and
reading can take you.
And today we have young people
who will join us to have fun
with books!
Ms. Dolly Parton has been
recognized many times for her
dedication to the power of
learning and for more than two
decades her imagination library
has helped hundreds of thousands
of children worldwide, giving
them high-quality books to own.
own.
No matter what their family's
income
and in 2014 she was awarded the
Best
Practices Award from the Library
of Congress Literacy Foundation
so today we
are pleased we will be part of a
milestone.
The Imagination Library is about
to
give away their
100 millionth book, that's so
many I
could
barely -- 100 millionth book and
we are humbled -- plagues
applause that that book will
join with millions of others at
the Library of Congress.  That
book will be given to us today.
So when the foundation started
years ago, the first books were
distributed to the Tennessee
County
where Dolly grew up and now it
is a worldwide phenomenon.
So without further ado I would
like to share with you a video
about the Imagination Library.
>> Dolly Parton's long-time
passion project passing on the
gift of reading
the news hour's special John M
arrow has the story.  story.
>> Hello! Hello! --
>> Most of you are probably
familiar with Dolly Parton but
to some Dolly Parton is more
than a country music star.
>> Everywhere I go the kids call
me the
.
(Video playing.
)
(Applause.)
>> Now, please welcome, multi
award
winning singer, song writer and
philanthropyist, Ms. Dolly
Parton!
>> Hello!
(Applause.)
>> Thank you so much, hi there!
Wow, hi up there!  there!
Well, it's nice to be here just
in this wonderful place, D.C.
, and certainly here in the
Library of
Congress what a Well, it's nice
to be here just in this
wonderful place, D.C., and
certainly here in the Library of
Congress what a beautiful
building you have here?
>> It's been called Well, it's
nice to be here just in this
wonderful place, D.C., and
certainly here in the Library of
Congress what a beautiful
building you have here?
>> It's been called the most
beautiful building in
Washington, D.C.
>> I think they're probably
right.
It's a beautiful day for us and
I'm so happy and excited to be
here and I was watching the film
back will on the phone they had
and I was watching all that and
seeing how these things have
happened through the years I'm
proud and honored to be here
today with you.
>> We're honored that you're
here because as you know
here because as you know --
>> Did you want to sit?
>> Would you like to
>> We're honored that you're
here because as you know --
>> Did you want to sit?
>> Would you like to sit?
>> Why not?
>> They've seen us and they
know, because I'm interested and
a lot of our
guests are interested in just
how all of this got started!
What inspired you to create
this?  This is such a great
program.
>> You have the idea, the
Imagination Library, I guess
everybody has their story and a
lot of you may or may not
know about me personally, but I
grew up in the smoky mountains
of east Tennessee, in a large
family, there were 12 of us kids
and my dad was a hard-working
man, he group up in a family of
14 or 15 kids and my dad never
had a chance to go to school.
And daddy not couldn't read or
write
but he was the smartest person
that I've every known so I
wanted to do something
special for him as the years
went by, I saw how it -- he
thought he couldn't learn to
read after he was grown, it was
just one of those things and I
had the idea to do something
special for him, you know, in
the Bible where it talks about
honor your father and your
mother, I don't think that
necessarily means
just to obey them, I think it
means to bring honor to their
name if you can.
So I got my daddy involved with
this program.
I wanted him to feel like he was
part of something special.
So we started the Imagination
Library, where we were giving
books to the
children in our home county, in
severeSevere Cath, where we were
born and raised.
And it became such a popular
program the governor of
Tennessee at that time thought
the idea was so great they took
it all over Tennessee.
Later it went on into Canada and
now we're all over the world in
different parts of the world.
So my dad got to live long
enough to see a lot of it come
into being.
He took such pride in the So my
dad got to live long enough to
see a lot of it come into being.
He took such pride in the fact
that
the little kids call me the
"book lady" so it started from a
true place in my heart and it's
done so much good for so many
people through the years.
>>
>> How does it feel to be called
the "book lady"?
You do so much, you sing and
write and You do so much, you
sing
you're known as the "book lady
You do so much, you sing and
write and you're known as the
"book lady" did you ever think
you would be the "book lady"?
>> That never crossed my mind
because I personally didn't like
school!
(Laughter.)
I do more homework now at night
working on these programs than I
every did all the years that I
was in school.
I never thought about being the
book
lady, the painted lady, yes, the
overaxe
guerre rated, overdressed lady,
but that
just goes to show you you can't
judge a
book by looking at the cover!
the painted lady, yes, the
overaxe guerre rated,
overdressed lady, but that just
goes to show you you can't judge
a book by looking at the cover!
(Applause.)
>> Right?
>> That's right, you can't tell.
You love books and reading, were
there books You love books and
reading, were there books that
shaped you?  You had favorite
books?
>> Well, we didn't have books in
our home because there were so
many of us
kids, and daddy told us not to
bring
books home dos kids pee on 'em,
chew on
them they can, whatever, so I
didn't get to bring books home
but one book in the home was the
Bible and my mother used to read
from the Bible and tell us Bible
stories so that was the first
book that we had in our home.
And the one that meant the most.
It has followed me more than any
other book through my life,
actually.
>> And you keep
>> And you keep reading it?
>> I do. In fact I love to read
-- excuse me, I have tissues,
everywhere!  I need one right
now!  now!
I'll just wait until someone --
but, anyway, I love to read and
I do whatever it takes to -- but
I actually loved, you know, just
anytime I was in school I
loved all the ferry tales, I
wanted to
read about the kings and the
Queens and the traveling so
books have always been a great
thing for me.
>> But with your busy schedule
how did you have time to read
because
>> But with your busy schedule
how did you have time to read
because you were performing and
doing so many things?
>> I always take time to read.
I think for anybody that loves
to read you will find the time
to read.  I do some of my best
thinking when I'm readin', if
you know what I mean.  I read 52
books a year, a book a week.
>> Wow!
>> So I've always been a reader,
but
there is a part of my brain that
kinda
can think of other things while
I am actually reading and I have
always loved to read because I
think in books, with kids, too,
with the books that they read
it inspires you to dream, and if
you can dream, that leads you to
success and to other things.
That's why I think it's so
important to get the books in
the hands of all these special
little kids so they can start
early and go late with 'em!
>> And they love it. So you
make time for reading.  reading.
Does any of the reading help you
with some of your song writing
and some of the Does any of the
reading help you with some of
your song writing and some of
the things that you read about?
>> These are good questions and
yes, it does, because I'm really
inspired by just people in
general.
Just like the little kids, a lot
of
things that I write I have a
children's CD out called "I
believe in you" and a
lot of the songs from that were
inspired by the books that are
in the Imagination
Library and the Little Engine
that Could is the first book we
give out in the Imagination
Library and I think it talks
about how to build confidence
and to know that you can if you
think you can and I really am
inspired by look at these faces
today.  I will feel something or
think something and who knows
what idea it
might trigger in me later on to
write a song about.
When you write you go by
feelings and what touches you
and how it touches you and you
find a clever way to put it into
a song.
>> You mentioned that sometimes
the books can spire feelings and
things in children and I know
that you started the library
because you believed in what
books mean and could mean to
children.  I know I've seen it
happen and I've felt it as a
child.
>> You of all people would know
because you've been doing this
for how many years?  You said
long before you got to this
beautiful building!
>> Too long!
I remember the books that
inspired me when I was young and
you believe that, too?
>> Yeah, I do.
I really think that -- we're
inspired
by everything and children
themselves
inspire me and children do, you,
too, because you work with them.
In every little child there is a
whole world and they're going to
see it and make things come true
in their little world and
they're going to add to the
world as they see fit according
to their talents and their
personalities, that's why it's
so important that they love to
love books and learn to read and
be inspired by that.
Because just like with my dad,
my dad couldn't read but he
really was smart.  smart.  He
picked up on things and he was
very intuitive.  It's my belief
if you can read, even if you
don't have the money to go to
school, you can especially
anymore, you
can just -- you can find a book
-- if you can read, on anything
that you want to know, you can
self-educate yourself and go to
college, even, you can pick up
those kinds of books even if you
can't get outside your house you
can find a book on any subject
and you can educate yourself to
where you can know about
things and actually just
increase your intelligence and
your -- just the whole world
around and you inspire other
people with that.
>> And what about owning a book
and saying this is my book!
It's got my name in it!
>> That's what I love about the
Imagination Library because that
was one of the things we thought
was so important when we first
started it.
And so we wanted the children to
have that book.  They get a book
for those of you that don't know
the whole thing, I guess they
talked about some of it, but
children get a book from the
time they're born
they get a book a month until
they start kindergarten, so we
send a book in the mail with
their name on it, it's not in
care of mom and dad it's got
their little name on it and they
love to think this is mine!
They wait at the mailbox, get
their book, and to them it's
personal.  So they're going to
take that in the
house and make somebody read it
to 'em because this is mu stuff,
my stuff, my stuff!
(Laughter.)
So I think that is has been a
real important thing because
they also share it with other
kids.  We're so happy we're such
a part of that and of all the
things I have done in my life
and it's been a lot, because
I've been around a long time but
this is one of the most precious
things and the proudest I am of
any program that I've every been
involved in in my life is
working with the little kids.
>> And you should be, because
after getting a book a month
they're going to have their own
>> And you should be, because
after getting a book a month
they're going to have their own
little library.
>> Yeah, they do.
>> In their houses, this will be
their library and their books
>> And you should be, because
after getting a book a month
they're going to have their own
little library.
>> Yeah, they do.
>> In their houses, this will be
their library and their books
and they can pull 'em out.
>> And they love that. They
love sharing that with kids!
>> You mentioned, though,
sometimes you
get letters that talk about what
happens after they're not in the
program.
>> Yeah, actually we get a lot
of letters when the kids are in
the program, we get letters all
the time
from parents and kids, but some
of the sweetest letters we get
-- in fact I'll
never forget the first one I got
was from a little boy that had
graduated from the Imagination
Library, he was 6 years old and
he was bummed out about it!
(Laughter.)
He was really mad because he
just wanted me to continue to
send him books!
He thought this is just not
fair, this is just not right
that I be can't continue to get
my books!  That's how important
it is to them.
I wrote him back a sweet letter
and explained how we do it and
that's why -- he was being
prepared because he was using
his mind to think about all
that!
We get a lot of sweet letters
and we treasure every one of
them.
>> And then he can get a library
card.
>> Yeah!
(Chuckles.)
>> Did you ever think you would
get to 100 million books when
you started
(Chuckles.)
>> Did you ever think you would
get to 100 million books when
you started?  That's phenomenal!
>> Not when we started. Like I
said, it was a very personal
thing when we started and I just
hoped
it would do good in in our
county, but at that time it was
something I was doing for my dad
and the kids in our home county.
Thank the Lord, he was good!
David Dodson who is the
President of the Imagination
Library, stand up there
for a second, David!
(Applause.)
He works so hard and he makes me
look
really good, I take a lot of
credit for
a lot of work that David and
these folks at the Imagination
Library they do.  He travels all
over the world making sure that
all these wonderful things
happen, making sure that all the
things that we brag about can
happen.
I just get out and talk about it
and do my part but it's always
like that with anything that
you're proud of!  It takes a
whole bunch of people to make
things happen and we owe the
real thing to the communities
and all the people that
participate, all the
organizations that get involved
and they're the ones that are
making my dreams come true.
It's just one of those things
that everybody takes a lot of
pride in.
Because if you're doing
something with children how can
you not feel good about that!
Look at 'em?  Hi there!  Hello!
So, anyway, it's a good feeling
all around, it's a win-win as
they say.
>> As I said, at the beginning,
we are
so honored that the
100 million will be given to the
Library of Congress for our
youngsters.
We have an unveiling --
>> I want to say how honored I
am before we pull that little
thing up that you have taken
this to heart and that you have
taken this in and that we will
now
have this book that I can
actually have here forever for
all the children all over the
world certainly in the United
States of America here in D.C.
It's a wonderful place to have
this.
Hopefully through the years we
have 100 million books so far
and maybe we
will be back for our billionth
book, wouldn't that be nice!
You want to see what's under
there?
>> It's a beautiful story, there
it is, 100 millionth book!
>> This is the coat of many
colors which is a little story
-- this lady right here, let me
mention her name, this is --
what's your name again?
(Laughter.)
>> This is the person who drew
--
>> Yeah, she illustrated this
book and
we appreciate your name is Brook
Hughes and she illustrated this
and I hope you had as much fun
drawing this as I did writing
it.
>> I did, it was an honor to be
part of the project and I loved
getting to illustrate your song.
>> Everybody loves it, this song
is important to me because my
mother -- I
was talking about my dad, my dad
was so very important but my
mother to have 12
kids and make 'em all feel
special with no money, she had
all the love in the world and
it's about the little story
about -- she told me the story
about
Joseph and the coat of many
colors
because it was getting
wintertime and
she made my coat and momma made
that and she had the foresight
to give me pride in the coat of
many colors so this book is more
than a story and it's more than
a song, it's about love, it's
about
attitude, and actually it's
turned out to be an antibullying
book.  They use this in Dallas
rooms to talk
about antibullying, and I want
kids to know it is okay for you
to be how you are and who you
are.  It's good to be different.
We can't all be the same but we
have we have to love the
differences and accept the
differences in each other too.
This book is about love and
understanding.  Thank you.
>> And thank you.
I see you have the coat here.
>> This little coat is a replica
of the
coat that my mom made for me
because
momma used to -- is people used
to send
us boxes of scraps because momma
made the quilts for our bed and
the curtains for our windows,
and she didn't have
enough of one fabric to make me
a coat so that's why she used
the pieces and that inspired her
to tell me the story from the
propel.  That's what this coat
-- we actually -- this coat,
that little song and the story
has lived forever, we had a
couple
of movies on TV about the little
coat
and it got good ratings, so it
shows people are about name and
they are about
love and it's good to feel that
warmth and that love about
parents because this
day and time we don't have
enough family stuff, there is so
much stuff going on out there
that little kids -- I love being
able to touch the kids and tell
them stories and for them to
feel what it was like back then
but it's how it should be now
with the love and
acceptance and understanding of
notparents because this day and
time we don't have enough family
stuff, there is little kids -- I
love being able to so much stuff
going on out there that touch
the kids and tell them stories
and for them to feel what it was
like back then but it's how it
should be now with the love and
acceptance and understanding of
not only just others but your
parents as well.
>> Well, we have also a special
announcement.
The Library of Congress is
partnering
with the Imagination Library and
to celebrate the program and
what we are
doing, the last Friday in every
month is going to be a special
Imagination Library story time.
>> Yay!
>> And they will be available
and it
will be live streamed to
libraries throughout the country
so people can participate.  We
are delighted that you have
agreed to kick it off.  off.
You are actually going to read
right here and start the
Imagination Library story time
at the Library of Congress.
>> Well I can do that.
I guess you want me to I guess
you want me to read the coat of
many colors book, right?
>> And we would love for you to
read this book!
>> Are we going down?
>> I think we're going to go
down because --
>> Is there a chair there?
Oh, they're going to have me
come down there, so I will be --
you be careful, hold on to me
and I'll hold on to him.  him.
Okay.  Hello!  Hello!  Hello!
Hello kiddies!  You want me to
read a book to you?  You do?
Well I'm gonna!
I gotta get my book lady glasses
on though so I can see!  How's
that?
Do I look like the book lady
now?  Hi.
This is called -- it says Dolly
Parton, that's my name and
what's your name?  Nice to see
you, Sammy.  Sammy.
This says "coat of many colors"
that's supposed to me me when I
was a little girl wearing her
coat of many colors.  Let me
find my real page here.  here.
So it starts with all these
pretty
pictures of my mom and my dad
and my pretty pictures of my mom
and my dad and brothers and So
it starts with all these my
brothers and sisters in here so
this
says "back through the years I
go wondering once again back to
the seasons of my youth.  I
recall a box of rags that
someone gave us and how my momma
put those rags to use.
There were rags of many colors
but every piece was small.  I
didn't have a coat and it was
way down in the fall.
So momma sewed the rags
together, she
sewed every piece with love and
made my coat of many colors that
I was so proud of.
As momma sewed she told a story
from the Bible she had read
about a coat of many colors
Joseph wore and then she said, I
hope this coat will bring you
good luck and happiness.
And I couldn't wait to wear it,
and momma blessed it with a
kiss.
So with patches on my britches
and holes in both my shoes, in
my coat of many colors I hurried
off to school.
Just to find the others laughing
and
making fun of me in my coat of
many colors that momma made for
me.
In my coat of many colors that
my
momma made for me, made only
from rags but I wore it so
proudly!
Although we had no money, I was
rich
as I could be, in my coat of
many colors momma made for me.
So with pooches my britches and
holes in both my shoes, in my
coat of many colors I hurried
off to school.
Just to find the others laughing
and making fun of me, in my coat
of many colors that momma made
for me.
And I couldn't understand that,
because I felt I was rich!
I told 'em of the love momma
sued in every stitch.
I even told 'em all that story
momma
told me while she sewed and why
my coat of many colors was worth
more than all their clothes.
But they didn't understand it
and I
tried to make them see that one
is only tidings only if they
choose to be.
It's true we had no money, but I
was
rich as I could It's true we had
no money, but I was rich as I
could be, in my coat of many
colors (singing.)momma made for
me.  me.  Can you says momma
made it just for me.  The end.
end.
(Applause.
)
'Cuz momma made it just for me.
The end.
(Applause.)
I'm going to go back up on stage
for a minute.  minute.  Okay.
>> That was so nice!
>> There we are, I thought,
well, I got to that part I
thought why not sing that little
part in case they hadn't heard
that.
>> Well, not only will the
Library of
Congress have the 100 million
100 millionth book, all the
young people today who have
heard the story, you're going
>> Well, not only will the
Library of Congress have the 100
millionth book, all the young
people today who have heard the
story, you're going to get your
own copy of a "Coat of many
colors
>> Well, not only will the
Library of Congress have the 100
millionth book, all the young
people today who have heard the
story, you're going to get your
own copy of a "Coat of many
colors".
>> Yes, you are!
>> You can take it when you
leave and you're going to have a
special CD, something that you
can play with the music and you
can hear Ms.
Part Ms.
Parton's voice, too, so we are
glad you could be here.
Remember, reading is fun, so we
have   Remember, reading is fun,
so we have the book lady and the
>> You can take it when you
leave and you're going to have a
special CD, something that you
can play with the music and you
can hear Ms. Parton's voice,
too, so we are glad you could be
here.the book lady and the
library lady and a new
partnership.
>> Yes, we do!
>> For the Library of Congress.
Thank you, everyone!
(Applause.)
>>
>> All right, are we heading
out?
>> We're going
>> All right, are we heading
out?
>> We're going to head out and
give out
>> All right, are we heading
out?
>> We're going to head out and
give out books.
>> Thank you everybody?
>> Thank you so much.
.